god this is beautiful fantastic okay we
got it we got to talk about this some
little exercise that you were doing he
said hey Amy my butt is coming for ya
did you see that I guess I you've seen
it yeah dude were you able to walk yeah
your mouth I'm barely low I was not able
to walk no I'm sorry sorry sorry sorry
you guys make a comedy doing people
don't even realize it now where are you
with a little sore huh yes did you see
those things yes I did it I hello
jealous I'm like oh that's how she
doesn't feel right don't do it even my
even our trainer who was like telling me
I need to do so don't don't do I saw you
do it now that it already started cuz I
was like if I can have it you know like
her you know I get it
that's hard work and a lot of genetics I
don't know thank you mom thank you
grandma
thank you Justin throw them in there
Justin congratulations on the nomination
thank you so much does it feel to be
here tonight a me it feels amazing I
mean it's just it's like um it's a
surreal dream and
I mean you know these things come run
you never know if this will ever happen
again so just trying to enjoy every
moment of it but it does kind of feel
like we're just floating floating along
and smiling a lot my cheeks hurt a lot
that's a good thing right
a good thing I do react when you heard
she got the nominees I'm more geeked out
than she is I think I found out before
you did yeah like wow I was just
randomly yeah that's why the time was
just a little funky and I didn't I
didn't want to I didn't want to bring it
up so she called me she's like guess
what and I was like I know what and yeah
I'm just so proud of ya I watched how
hard she worked you know not just as a
lead actress but also producing the
material from from scratch you know so
I'm just I'm so proud having here yeah
we do a lot of things together well we
know they're together yeah I like him
wrecked me in something I think that's
the moon what do you think about that I
love it I gotta let you go but I guess
we got about the 25th anniversary and
Mickey Mouse coming out but you know
that Mickey Mouse Club it's the 20 2015
over Surrey I didn't know that I did not
know that I love that I'm breaking news
breaking news just got to do something
in honor of it that makes me feel old
sorry you don't look old at all
you
[Applause]